Here are the conjugates and here are the products. Great work if you found at
least four of those. We know for the conjugate we just change the sign between
the two terms so the conjugate of 1 minus root 11 is 1 plus root 11. Here we
change the subtraction sign to a positive. And here we change the positive sign
to a negative. For the products we want to use our pattern for the difference
of two squares. We know the product of two binomials with differing signs will
be a squared minus b squared. So we can square a which is 1 here And squared b,
which is the root of 11. One squared equals 1, and root 11 squared equals 11.
We find the difference of these squares, which is 1 minus 11, which equal
negative 10. For the second one, when we square the a term, we'll have 9 times
2, we square the 3 and we square the root 2. For b squared, or square two which
is four, and we square the square root of three, which equals three. We know
nine times two is 18, and four times three is 12. This gives us a final answer
of six. And for the last one, we have negative five squared for the a term and
six root two squared for the b. Negative five squared is 25 and 6 root 2
squared is 36 times 2 or 72. 25 minus 72 equals negative 47.